daily wire has this story NASCAR faced
backlash online over the weekend after
it suspended a driver for quote his
actions on social media Noah gragson was
suspended by NASCAR and Legacy motor
club after he reportedly liked a meme on
Instagram that mocked George Floyd's
death and we'll show you that Meme in a
second before we do
let's get let's get the whole story and
this guy was fired for not even he
didn't post a meme
um he didn't even like retweet it to
propagate it get in front of more people
he just liked it
and by the way the way you know I don't
I don't like tweets at all but uh people
that that do that it's not even even
though it says like sometimes they do it
as a people do that because they're just
bookmarking it so they can go back later
people have different reasons for
clicking like on something
or maybe just because they like it
so who knows maybe maybe he bookmarked
it maybe he saw the meme and that said
you know this is an interesting thing I
want to revisit it later think more
about it who knows who knows what his
motives were
but all he did was click like on it
click the little little heart button on
it
NASCAR said in a statement quote NASCAR
fully supports Legacy motor club's
decision to suspend Noah gragson
following his actions on social media
Nascar has determined that graxon has
violated the member conduct section of
the 2023 NASCAR rule book and has placed
them under indefinite suspension
Legacy motor club sent a statement we've
made the decision to suspend noagrax an
effective immediately regarding his
actions that do not represent the values
of our team
Josh Berry will drive the number 42
entry for this weekend Nascar Cup Series
race at Michigan
now
now we get immediately to the inevitable
here so there was no there's no uh with
Neo there was a little bit of lag time
there's a little bit of time in between
but in this case right away we get
uh the next paragraph which tells us
that Gregson apologized for liking the
meme writing quote I am disappointed in
myself for my lack of attention and
actions on social media I understand the
severity of this situation he continued
I love and appreciate everyone I try to
treat everyone equally no matter who
they are I messed up plain and simple
so another coward it's a coward Bonanza
today that's what we're dealing with
um and and yet again as always is this
going to do anything for him
is it going to be invited back into the
fold he's gonna get his job back
all the people that have torn him down
and said that he's a horrible racist and
all the rest of it and he's terrible
he's a fascist whatever they're saying
about him uh are they gonna
are they going to go back and say well
you know he apologized and hey let's
let's give him another chance let's be
it was just a meme guys and he
apologized for it and let's be
reasonable about it okay we don't have
to tear this guy's whole life apart for
me he did apologize are any of them
going to say that is even one person in
the outrage mob gonna say that the
answer is no of course not no one's
going to say that
which is why
even as a matter of just pure
we don't have to appeal to your courage
even
it'd be good if we could like I wish we
could appeal to your courage if you're
Noah gragson or neho
and just say
you know have have some backbone stand
by what you said don't cave to the Mob
just don't do it
have a little bit of Courage I wish we
could say that that's a non-starter with
a lot of people there's but we don't
even have to appeal that it's also just
pure self-interest
it's like the not only is it the best
thing to do morally to stand by your
actions and not to Cave to the Mob it's
also just strategically the best
approach
because you you're already
labeled this way and you're never going
to get that label off you whatever the
out whatever the leftist mob is saying
about you they're going to say that
about you forever now
sorry to say that's just the way it's
going to be
um but you do at least have some people
defending you and sticking up for you
and so you might as well for Pure
self-preservation your best move
is to stick by them and to stand by what
you said and that's why um Gregson
should have come out smartest strategic
thing for him to say is to come out and
say hey you know what
it was a joke it's a meme all you people
crying about it you're all a bunch of
Hypocrites and cry babies
okay you know that if you agree with me
politically and I I like to meme you
know going the other way you'd have no
problem with it you're all a bunch of
frauds and phonies I apologize to none
of you kiss my ass
you disgusting cry bullies
you know what and then he goes and post
the meme again here's the meme again
I'm gonna blow this meme up and put her
on a billboard on the highway now
because of you people that's what I'm
gonna do
that's what he should have said
but he didn't instead he uh you
apologize this if I understand the
severity that's the part that gets me
the most I understand the severity of it
really the severity of this situation
what is tell me Noah what's the uh
what's the severity
of you like a a NASCAR guy a NASCAR
driver liked a meme uh really what's the
severity of that
it's a severity of the situation
um no that's what you say if like
I I don't know that's what your doctor
says to you maybe if if they're letting
you know that you have terminal cancer
to talk about the severity of the
situation
there's no severity to you liking a meme
no one's hurt by it
that hurts no one no one's actually
offended
um all people pretending to be offended
are actually happy
okay because you're a NASCAR driver
you're automatically suspect as far as
they're concerned politically and
ideologically and so they have a chance
to drag you down it's it's also just fun
it's a recreation for them
they'll rip your life apart and move on
to the next one it's all fun for them so
they're happy they're really happy about
it
nobody was hurt it's not a serious
situation but he apologizes I don't know
about you but this summer heat in
Nashville feels hotter than it's been in
years thanks to the Heat and the
inflation we're feeling the heat in more
ways than one so the one thing I'm not
sweating this summer though is my meat
price thanks to good ranchers my price
is locked in for two years might be
thinking a price lock guarantee on meat
yes it's amazing and you need it you
need to try it good ranchers is the only
meat company locking in your price with
our industry first price lock guarantee
since 2021 they've been helping people
combat the inflation of the meat aisle
as well as the mystery of it too it
turns out that over 85 percent of
grass-fed beef is imported from overseas
so not only is it is it a store-bought
meat expensive but it's often low
foreign quality too when you subscribe
to good ranchers you get a guaranteed
price and a trusted 100 American source
for your favorite Cuts you can save on
your beef chicken and pork by locking in
your price today every single Steakhouse
quality cut is individually wrapped and
flash frozen to make Meal Time easy
visit goodranchors.com use my code Walsh
for 30 off any box that's promo code
Walsh at goodranchors.com
goodranchors.com American Meat delivered
now
before we go any further
I think we should probably take a look
at this meme uh in in the interest of
Journalism this offensive unsightly meme
so let's put it up on the screen here
so there's the meme that he liked and as
you can see
it's uh it says under the knee under the
knee and then it's George Floyd's face
on uh the body of a lobster
recalling of course Sebastian
from The Little Mermaid who sang uh
famously under the sea
and so that's the joke now
there's a joke there that's what it is
now I want to say something
I don't see what I want you to leave
this up I want you to leave this up the
entire time as we talk about it
I don't see why we would assume
that this is meant to mock George Floyd
I don't see I mean Sebastian's a lovable
character
this imagines George Floyd reborn as
this lovable character
um I think those morning George Floyd's
death could even be comforted by this I
think it's I think it's deeply I think I
mean there's you could make the argument
that no Gregson
wanted to comfort those who are still
mourning the passing of George Floyd
these three years later
and he's saying you know George Floyd's
in a better place now he's reincarnated
as a lobster deep in the sea
why is that a bad thing bad thing
some people believe in in reincarnation
we're gonna be judgmental of those
people
so that's what I take from this
I think if you're really mourning George
Floyd you should be it should make you
happy to think well you know what maybe
George Floyd is in the ocean
singing songs to a mermaid
in a much better place
but if it is and this is a big if
this is a huge if if it's meant to be
mocking
which I think we don't know that but
we'll never know
uh if it is then the only reason why
this would be considered way way out of
bounds and just absolutely awful you
know the kind of thing that you would
lose your job over
is if you agree
that George Floyd is a martyr
and a saint and not a violent criminal
and drug addict who died as a direct
result of his own life choices and his
own behavior
you know
and and
um
and if you believe the latter right if
you if you believe uh what is in fact
the reality which is that George Floyd
again was a violent criminal and a
career criminal drug addict and died as
a direct result of his own actions
then this kind of thing because again if
it is meant to mock him then you're
making fun of somebody dying so it's in
poor taste at worst that's what it is
not something you lose your job over you
would lose your job over that
it only becomes
a severe situation and something where
people have been hurt and deeply funded
if you you think that George Floyd is a
saint this is Saint George Floyd he's a
he's a great man a wonderful member of
his community one of the greatest
Americans this country has ever produced
and that's why he has murals and that's
why his statue is now and he's deserving
of all of that
that's the only way that this becomes uh
this this this graduates to the level of
something that you'd lose your job of
because then it becomes an act of
blasphemy
and that's how and that's how it's being
treated this is this is why the left
reacts something like this is because
it's not because you're it's a it's a
joke and poor taste about someone who
died they don't care about that
like nobody really can get everyone
understand you know morbid humor is
something that everyone engages in
sometimes it's not a big deal
um most of people pretend to be offended
by this I guarantee there have been 9 11
and Holocaust jokes that those people
have laughed about and this is one guy
who died and they're and they're
pretending that they're it's a horrible
every single person who's by the way
every single person who's pretending to
be offended by that every single one of
them you check their Twitter account at
some point they've posted a meme mocking
say Ashley Babbitt who died on January
6th
so it's all it it you know
it's all a charade
and that's why they don't really care
it's not that well we never make jokes
about people who died we never do that
everyone's done that everyone has done
that
that's not the point for them it's
blasphemy is blasphemy against a sainted
hallowed blessed figure that's the way
that they see it
and that's the way NASCAR sees it
you know NASCAR and this is just the
latest example of this NASCAR is uh I
mean fully woke all the way
you know uh I mean they are
not quite NBA tier but they're close I I
would even in wokeness Factor over the
last several years I put them
it's like NBA is at the top of the woke
pyramid and uh and NFL is actually a few
notches below that and NASCAR's above
that now they're climbing the wok uh the
woke ladder
all right we could take that down now
George Floyd
in a better place hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there